the gyro can experience every single
generation hopefully if society doesn't
implode
we don't have nuclear war every single
generation is going to learn from the
mistakes of the past and hopefully
improve that's what we're hoping for and
we should be happy that we can look back
on a lot of these people and say we
understand now how deeply flawed they
were and what was wrong with George
Washington what's what was wrong with
Thomas Jefferson although he did you
know draft the Declaration of
Independence he was a slave owner and
this is one of the contradictions of our
society in our culture the fathered kids
with a slave I mean yes yes I mean you
don't have to shortchange the evils of
human beings in order to recognize
either the direction of American history
or recognize the good things about
people people are a little more complex
than I think we want to think of them
yes and this is one of the arenas that
this sort of gets back to the point
about the system if you recognize that
human beings are capable of great sin
and also capable of doing great things
what you really want is a system that
that of checks and balances that
prevents people from gaining too much
power to hurt other people and what you
also want to recognize is that the flaws
of human beings are not necessarily the
flaws of the system and that just
changing the system is not going to
change the underlying flaws of human
beings which means you actually have to
think through the policies that you're
promulgating before you implement them
clearly if you say this you're not
paying attention to what happened at
Chas or chop because they they had it
nailed it was paradise for a short
period of time that's one of my favorite
stores great of this year because these
people basically took over this gigantic
chunk of Seattle and said we're going to
show you how it's done they wind up
being the police they want a beating the
[ __ ] out of people who did anything they
didn't want to do including film things
they wind up see you saw murder you saw
massive graffiti you certainly saw
borders there were borders put up they
kept cops from coming in they kept a lot
of people from coming in and up
journalists the big up journalists they
took over private property so they
appropriated private property these are
not buildings they built they didn't
make a deal they didn't barter they
didn't have some sort of a beautiful
mutually beneficial agreement with these
people to know in these buildings no
[ __ ] you they took him over the
took them over and started
spray-painting [ __ ] all over them it's
crazy but it shows you like your
childlike childlike idea of what you can
do that's better you don't take in that
you don't really understand that the
founding fathers really did put into
play into place all these checks and
balances to keep someone from abusing
power and as much as Trump would like to
overcome all that you see time and time
again he's a great example in in many
ways of how this system really is
beautifully engineered from 300 [ __ ]
years because it's because the phasers
didn't understand the the problem of
human nature which is people want power
and they want to hurt other people very
often and you still need government in
order to do things but there better be
broad scale agreement on the things you
want to do or a small majority of people
can really hurt a huge minority of
people right this is what they call
tyranny of the mob right they were
they're much afraid of this and and
that's stuff that is worth remembering
you know the tearing down that system
because you want to build something more
beautiful if it looks like Chazz or chop
that ain't a thing what's this
idealistic they have blinders on they
have this this narrow tunnel vision view
of what they think this utopian future
could be I think they think that human
beings are gonna be fundamentally
transformed by a different system yeah
so look at the problems one of the
biggest problems we have in American
politics is the myopia with which we
look at the United States so when you're
dating somebody it's very easy to see
all the problems with the person you're
dating when you're married to someone
it's certainly easy for my wife to see
all the problems with me and there are
plenty but when she looks at all the
other people then she's like okay well
he's less flawed than the others right
when you look at the United States it's
very easy to see all the different flaws
in the United States because of course
they exist this is a society filled with
humans 330 million of them but when you
look abroad and you look at other
examples of civilizations over time and
then you look back at the United States
you think maybe the system isn't quite
that bad because the fact is that for
all the problems we got the biggest
problems that humanity faces and has
faced are not happening in the United
States they're happening everywhere else
China right now is shipping Weger
Muslims on trains after shaving their
heads to concentration camps where they
are being forcibly sterilized there are
actual problems on planet earth that is
not to say there aren't problems in the
United States but they are not the same
in terms of degree and they are not the
same in terms of scope and to pretend
that the system of the
it states needs to be ripped down from
the inside and that if you build a
beautiful new system you will shape
humanity such that we are all Saints and
no sinners you're out your mind
[Applause]